there's still five more hours of  shopping I know tom is checking it out  but I wanted to highlight a couple of  things that the different trainings  websites are selling thanks to our  production and assistant Joe for coming  up with this you've got a t-shirt that  translates into single forever bachelor  forever that's a play on the De Beers  line and diamond is forever on the far  left there is also a double boiler  that's been discounted heavily that you  use the steam food and also a house I'm  JD comm bar fire systems okay we should  point out Joe is our secret weapon folks  just quietly Phil yes we have everyday  with a drip of data from some just  saying hey [ __ ] you know nothing about  Asia shut up  she does her Chris Christie thing she  does she's doing it right now I can see  her offset doing it  alright John thank you for that yeah  Alibaba to tally up the numbers this  morning